President Biden revealing to Americans
just how empty his 2024 campaign will be
the big guy doesn't have any new ideas
instead he's doubling down on demonizing
half the country after Trump's blowout
win in Iowa saying quote this election
was always going to be me and you
against extreme Maga Republicans it was
true yesterday and it'll be true
tomorrow not to be outdone VP kamla
Harris has her own delusional take on
Trump well let me just tell you this no
matter who the Republican nominee is
we're winning we're winning do you
you've seen the numbers you know a lot
do you think Donald Trump at this point
is a foregone
conclusion I don't know but look if it
is Donald Trump we've beat him before
and we'll beat him
again where did she get that confidence
Sandra he's a 33 I think she's less well
and insulting the Maga movement
considering and 10 caucus goers
considered themselves in our Fox News
voter analysis uh supporters of the make
America great again movement 74 Back
Trump uh 74% back Trump um it's bold uh
where does she get the confidence I
don't I don't know makes it up maybe I
don't know um it's an interesting
strategy it's if you don't have the if
you don't have the policy issues to tout
this is the this is the route you take
and I think that's fair to say a lot of
what we're going to see heading into
November yeah and Greg isn't it true
that it's all about division creating
them versus US yeah that's the game plan
uh you are the devil you will be
demonized and I think the the other side
needs to prepare for that and kind of
like step out of that and go this is
what they're going to do and ask how did
that work for America right when you
demonize half the country uh we're not
going to play that game we're not going
to do that we actually want their votes
you're going to write F them off we want
their votes so I think you really do
have to kind of uh uh stretch your hand
out to the people that are undecided and
say look at the Deeds not the words were
there any wars under Trump no was there
a border under Trump yes how much did
eggs and unleaded cost under Trump uh
who decriminalized crime was it Trump or
was it under Biden so I think you know I
think that you're going to be targeted
and we we get our show gets targeted
everybody gets targeted because we are
witnesses to these CRI
and you have to go after the witnesses
and scare them to shut them up all right
Jesse David Axelrod says that Biden
needs different messaging other than
Trump is a threat to democracy what
should their messaging
be well you can't message policy because
it's been a disaster and I'm not a
Democrat so I'm not going to pretend
like I care I like that eggs and
unleaded that's a good name for a band
so if Biden's calling Trump
extreme I'd Jiu-Jitsu that right on him
and I'd say you're backing CRT and sex
changes for kids in grade school you
broke the bank the border and women's
sports I mean your family's a freak Show
you have solar powered leaf blowers and
putting windmills on beaches you're
extreme it worries me because they have
a lot of money and Republicans are
splintering the money three ways in the
primary and Trump spending $100 million
on lawyers meanwhile the media is like
an in-kind contribution to the Democrats
cuz they have a 247 attack situation I
just have never seen such an
unpredictable election because you have
the oldest most unpopular sitting
president who's just sitting back and
Prosecuting his rival while he's just
laying back in an easy chair in Delaware
and then the media is colluding with the
Deep state to hatch this disinformation
campaign and censorship campaign and now
just the baby Boer establishment in
Washington DC is basically like lighting
everybody up in An Origin of tyranny and
Corruption and claiming they're trying
to save democracy meanwhile the rest of
the country is just watching football
and Netflix and complaining about the
weather this is like the weirdest
election
ever it's true are you watching no um I
watch what happened to your Eagle I
don't want to talk about it yeah what
happened to Jason Kelce well he retired
you'll have to see my one more thing
okay all right let's go back to you okay
so s say Biden has all this money is it
going to do him any good he's at 33% he
he's got problem um couple things one I
like her confidence but I don't you got
to have to add you you said the best
Afters you got to have policy
prescriptions if you're going to have
that confidence and we'll see uh what
happens they did beat Biden I mean Trump
once and we'll see if they can do it
again but you can't do it again if you
don't know some of the if you don't
focus on some of the basics every
presidential campaign depending on how
voters F the beginning of Summer which
is the proverbial Memorial Day how how
how expensive is gas on Memorial Day in
2024 will be a turning point point for
both campaigns too before that if the
Biden campaign if the Biden
Administration does not get serious
about border security does not lay out a
plan to address this and you're running
out of time you may have run out of time
uh this is an issue that all the polling
data shows the economy the border and
foreign policy and I think those issues
are combined in voters Minds around the
economy and their economic their
Economic Security Axel Rod is right this
threat to democracy remember it pulls
High because Republic think there's a
threat to democracy because of the way
Trump is being treated and Democrat
thinks there's a threat to democracy
because of the way Trump is being
treated the common denominated there is
Trump but it's divided so we shouldn't
get we shouldn't get too excited
Democrats shouldn't get too excited
about those numbers finally there are
150 to 250,000 voters in Six States who
are going to decide this race it's
provided that each side ramps up their
base and get the gets their their their
die Hearts to go out we know the states
Michigan Pennsylvania Georgia Arizona
amongst the four states if you're not
speaking to those voters to those
Independents and you're not going to
speak to him by shutting him off by
censoring him by suggesting that the
voter turnout was small so we shouldn't
be we shouldn't be concerned about it
you got to have a better message you got
to have a better plan you got to have a
better vision for the future whomever
does that will win whoever is in the
business of censoring is not likely to
win that's Joe Biden admit it now we
beat him
once okay hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now